que chacune allait être là pour
l'autre et que même si on faisait
insulté etc on allait réussir ensemble à
combattre ça comment tu te sens depuis
le départ de l'Insee
en colère
triste perdu tu reçois encore des
insultes regardez exemple et en fait ça
pote là à l'INSEE elle est pas prête je
dis c'est elle va rejoindre sa meilleure
amie quand tu lis ça Maylis
on peut voir que le conte s'appelle
l'Insee est enfin morte vous vous rendez
compte
parce que je vais vous dire ce qu'il a
fait le proviseur une fois qu'il y a une
rame il a demandé à être muté pour pas
avoir de problème moi je vous dis voilà
je le dis voilà je vous le dis comme ça
au moins ce sera fait voilà je vous le
dis on va pas les lâcher sur cette
histoire c'est vrai c'est vrai ou pas